Male grass gobys may be small, but some of
them are masters of manipulation when it comes
to the composition of their ejaculates.
Grass gobys are bottom-feeding fish endemic
to coastal waters of the mediterranean basin.
These small fish have an external fertilization
system - meaning the sperm isn’t deposited
inside the safe and secure space of a female’s
body.
Females deposit their eggs in small depressions
on the sea bottom, which males then fertilize,
directly exposing the sperm to the danger
of the open ocean.
But there’s more than one way for a male
goby to be reproductively successful...
There are two different types of goby males:
territorial and sneaker.
The territorial males are large and strong,
whereas the sneaker males are small and quick.
The territorial male guards an area where
a female lays her eggs, and he fertilizes
them once they have been deposited.
Sneaker males, on the other hand, hide nearby
and dart out at the exact moment that the
territorial males are fertilizing, and they
deposit some sperm of their own!
Ejaculates of territorial VS sneaker males
vary greatly in their composition.
Territorial males create a viscous, abundant
spew that is high in substances that help
the sperm to swim faster through the seawater
to the eggs.
The sneaker can take advantage of the speed-enhancing
compounds by mixing his ejaculate with the
territorial’s.
Any eggs that the sneaker male fertilizes
will then be protected by the larger, stronger
territorial male.
And by exploiting the benefits of the high-quality
ejaculates, the sneaky sneakers save energy.
Because,let’s face it - they are much smaller
and they don’t have any extra energy to
spare!
Take that tough guy!